Over the last few years, I've launched five
art competitions, and now the incredible art
from those competitions has a home.
Soul Arts.
A beautiful tome, carefully crafted, and full
of art inspired by Demon's Souls, Dark Souls,
Bloodborne, Sekiro, and Elden Ring.
To be clear, the book has no official link
to these games, but that's exactly what makes
the art within so creative.
These artists imagined places, bosses, and
weapons, that have never been visualised before...expanding
the worlds that we love in an exceptional
way.
Go beyond the Sixth Archstone, and read about
the Twisted City, where the Weaver gently
distorts the world..
Or skip ahead to the Unseen Lands, where artists
brought to life regions that we never got
to see in-game.
Few would have seen this piece from the "Imagining
Bloodborne 2" competition, which depicts Caryll's
terrible fate..
Nor this piece of Prosthetic art, where Sekiro
becomes equipped with a Pivoting Greatsword.
Then there's the chapter for Elden Ring..with
bosses and open worlds drawn from a time where
we knew absolutely nothing about the game.
So we'd be honoured if Soul Arts could earn
a place on your bookshelf, or coffee table.
This kickstarter is a real leap of faith,
but with your help, I know we can create something
that you'll come to treasure.
Here's a preview of your reward tiers:
A digital edition.
A cover art poster by Ricardo Emig.
The art book itself.
The art book with the slipcase..
An art exhibition bundle, featuring a collage
poster.
The benefactor bundle, where your name will
be listed at the back of the book
And a signed edition, from me.
I'll be back at the end of the video..but
for now, I'm going to pass over to Jason,
our publisher, who is going to explain things
in
a
bit
more detail.